voilà monsieur bonjour la marine
française a réussi son opération de
neutralisation des deux principaux
bâtiments de l'organisation greenpeace
ce matin les deux navires sont évacués
sous bonne escorte et les plongeurs qui
s'était introduit dans la zone de tir
ont tous été interpellés
roland sicard c'était la pièce maîtresse
du dispositif des écologistes de
greenpeace plus gros que le rainbow
warrior et surtout capable de recevoir
des hélicoptères un hélicoptère est
exactement alors c'est par hélicoptère
que les commandos de marine ont décidé
d'intervenir premier contact entre les
militaires et les écologistes pas de
violence ensuite c'est par la mer que
les renforts devaient arriver mais les
opérations d'abordage sont difficiles
les premiers hommes montent à bord mais
regardez en bas à gauche de l'écran
le bateau des commandos de marine est
renversé par une vague malgré cela le
greenpeace comme le rainbow warrior
auparavant émis sous contrôle pour les
militaires le plus dur est fait seul
reste de la flotte idées écologistes les
bateaux appartenant à de simples
particuliers
c'est pas du tout la même chose et en
plus je ne suis pas certain que les gens
qui sont venus là avec leur bateau est
très envie de rester
sélection auparavant dans le lagon de
murs euros à un zodiac des écologistes
accompagné par l'hélicoptère de
greenpeace avaient réussi à s'approcher
de la zone de tir de plongeurs
parviendront à descendre les militaires
les récupérant à leur remontée à la
surface
le rainbow warrior le rainbow warrior
navire amiral de la flotte lui avait été
arraisonné le premier les commandos
avaient dû utiliser les 6 et les
chalumeaux les écologistes s'étaient
barricadés à l'intérieur pour les
militaires l'important était d'éviter
toute violence opération est maintenant
terminée le greenpeace et le rainbow
warrior sont remorqués vers l'atoll
d'hao à 700 kilomètres de murs euros